no doubt millions of americans are
pumped up about the mega millions
jackpot the next drawing happening in
just a few hours from now now we sent jc
fernandez to dive head first into the
hive just over the border in arizona and
jc what's the vibe like down there
hey christian i'll tell you the vibe is
awesome because the anticipation of
possibly winning 1.2 billion dollars
we're at the last stop in arizona and
everyone says everyone's in a great mood
out here and rachel runs this whole
place how has this the past couple weeks
been for you it has been exciting i have
loved it all of the energy from
everybody wanting to win is beautiful
okay let's let's talk about tonight's
drawing what if someone does not win
what happens next well then it rolls
over to tuesday so that gives us
saturday sunday monday tuesday to buy
our next tickets um and it will be even
busier and even more exciting okay i
have faith that someone's gonna win in
here tonight 1.2 billion dollars this
lady right here she just bought her
tickets she sent you to buy land right
she buy lots of land with 1.2 billion
dollars but if it doesn't win tonight
it's gonna happen on tuesday would you
suggest people come tomorrow morning to
buy their tickets uh saturday will
definitely be slower than sunday monday
or tuesday and and so there's six we're
picking six numbers one through five uh
you're picking from a pool from one to
seventy number six that six number is
your your mega ball number yes and
that's where a lot of what 1 to 25
you're drawing from that is correct yes
and so real quick you're selling tickets
all day long how many people say to you
if i win i'm going to give you part of
the money
75
people coming in here saying that we'll
see if someone wins you have to give
them some money and and rachel before i
send it back do you guys get something
if you sell the winning ticket we do get
a little bonus
it's not that much but we do get
something i love it you guys have been
great and by the way they have the best
hamburgers in arizona is right here at
the last stop their kitchen is amazing
so come down here buy a lottery ticket
it may be a good burger i'll send it
back to you christian all right jc thank
you for that and obviously so many eager
are over this massive mega millions
prize 1.28 billion dollars and and just
so you know that's not the largest prize
in u.s history now back in 2018 one
person from south carolina won about 1.5
billion dollars now that's the largest
mega million prize but not the largest
lottery prize ever now we did some
digging and check this out in 2016
three tickets split the powerball prize
of wait for this
1.586
billion dollars life-changing money of
course right